Victor Victor  damage  we have them all late  and Worley  okay let me just make sure  where you guys coming from  don't know  Hudson yeah that's what you guys had I  don't I didn't get a good face you had  two black males over in black pants  neither one of my shirts on yeah right  that's what we got  what's your names man  um  okay everything checks out we'll get you  guys on here okay  you know we got  yeah  hold on hold on stay down stay down  all right stand up  of what you're walking from around the  corner from these burning people's house  so how'd you get to your grandest  people's house man they were just  walking we just seen them walking down  the street  I'm being serious okay  I got the key because my house keys  for sure  yes  it was just up too when we came had the  lights off  like hey there's two people right there  with no shirts  yeah  what's your name  [Music]  oh